A fair pervasive violation of the end-to-end argument are
home gateways, which often perform something called network address
translation. Now on a home network we have many
devices that connect to the network, but when we
buy service from our internet service provider we're typically
only given one public IP address. And yet we
have a whole variety of devices that we may
want to connect. Now the idea behind network address translation
is that we can give each of these devices a private IP address and there
are designated regions of the IP address space
that are for private IP addresses. One of
those is 192.168.0.0/16 and there are others, which
you go read about in RFC 3130. Each
one of these devices in the home gets
its own private IP address. The public internet,
on the other hand, sees a public IP address
which typically is the IP address provided by the
internet service provider. When packets traverse the home router,
which is often running a network address translation process,
the source address of every packet is rewritten to
the public IP address. Now when traffic comes back
to that public IP address, the network address translator
needs to know which device behind the NAT the
traffic should be sent to. So it uses a mapping of port numbers to identify
which device the return traffic should be sent
to in the home network. So the NAT
or the network address translator maintains a table
that says packets with the source IP address
of 192.168.1.51 and source port 1000 should be
rewritten to a source address of the public
IP address and a source port of 50878. Similarly, packets with a source IP
address of 192.168.1.52 and source port of
1000 should be rewritten to the public IP
address and a source port of 50879. Then when traffic returns to the NAT to
one of these addresses the NAT knows
that it needs to rewrite the destination address
on the return traffic to the appropriate destination
IP address and port that's in the private
network. So for outbound traffic, the NAT device
creates a table entry mapping the computer's local
IP address and port number to the public
IP address at a different port number. And
replaces the sending computer's non-routable IP address with
the gateway or the NAT public IP address.
It also replaces the sender's source port with a
different source port that allows it to demutiplex the
packets sent to this return address and port. For
inbound traffic to the home network, the NAT checks the
destination port on the packet, and based on the
port, it rewrites the destination IP address and port to
the private IP address in the table before forwarding
the traffic to a local device in the home network.